From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. If you're living in a city, you may have noticed new buildings popping up. A high rise here, a skyscraper there. These concrete jungles make urban living possible. They allow millions to live together in close proximity and allow modern economies to flourish. But is there something important missing in this picture? For most of the last two million years, humans lived in a natural world, relying on nature for food and shelter.
来自NPR，这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。如果你住在城市里，你可能已经注意到新建筑不断拔地而起。这里一座高楼，那里一栋摩天大楼。这些水泥森林让城市生活成为可能。它们让数百万人能够近距离共同生活，并使现代经济得以繁荣。但这幅画面中是否缺少了什么重要的东西？在过去二百万年的大部分时间里，人类都生活在自然界中，依靠大自然获取食物和庇护。
The amount of time we've spent in urban dwellings is a small sliver of the total time humans have spent on Earth. When you look at it this way, our shift from forest life to freeways and overflowing cities has been very recent and very dramatic. So how is this shift affecting our health, our mood, and our sense of calm?
我们在城市住宅中度过的时间，只是人类在地球上度过总时间的一小部分。当你这样看时，我们从森林生活向高速公路和拥挤城市的转变是非常近期的，也是非常戏剧性的。那么，这种转变如何影响我们的情绪、心情和内心的平静？
This week on Hidden Brain, think deeply. We continue our annual summer series, YouTube.O. Authenticity is contagious. I have been dragged into this all the way kicking and screaming. Ideas and advice about how you can respond to life's chaos. Just do it, just check to my inbox. Just chaos. You do it just check to my inbox. Just check, just check, just check to my phone real quick. With wisdom. Ming-Kuo has been studying the effects of nature on humans for more than 30 years. She works at the University of Illinois or Banna-Champaign. Early in her career, Ming studied research looking at the well-being of animals in zoos. Researchers found that even when animals were provided all the basics of food,
本周的 Hidden Brain，让我们深入思考。我们继续推出年度夏季系列，YouTube.O。真实具有传染性。我被硬生生地拉了进来，一路踢打尖叫。关于如何应对生活混乱的理念和建议。只管去做，去查收我的收件箱。只有混乱。你只管去做，去查收我的收件箱。去查收，去查收，去查收我的手机。充满智慧。明国（Ming-Kuo）研究自然对人类的影响已经超过30年。她在伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-香槟分校工作。在她职业生涯的早期，明研究了关于动物园动物福利的研究。研究人员发现，即使动物得到了食物、
safety, and shelter, they often failed to thrive. It turns out that zoo animals, first of all, are extremely expensive. They die at fairly alarming clips. And so, biologists have studied animals in the wild, and one of the ideas that they have is that there's this thing called habitat selection theory, which is that we are, we're wired for whatever habitat we evolved in. And so there seems to be this general kind of rule that animals who are in their quote unquote natural habitats will do much better. They thrive both in terms of physically will do much better they thrive both in terms of physically and psychologically and in terms of their social behaviors. So if zoo animals thrive in their natural habitat, some researchers have asked,
安全和庇护等所有基本需求，它们往往也无法茁壮成长。事实证明，首先，动物园里的动物极其昂贵。它们的死亡率相当惊人。因此，生物学家研究了野生动物，他们的观点之一是存在一种叫做“栖息地选择理论”的东西，也就是说我们天生适应我们进化的那个栖息地。因此似乎存在这样一个普遍规律：处于其所谓的自然栖息地中的动物会表现得好得多。它们在身体上、心理上以及社会行为方面都能茁壮成长。所以，如果动物园的动物在它们的自然栖息地中能茁壮成长，一些研究人员就提出了这样一个问题：
could this also be true for humans? Given that humans first evolved in the forest of Africa, could it be that depriving humans of this natural environment has effect similar to housing a zebra in a cage? We'll get to Ming's answer to that question in a moment, but first it's important to understand how she came to be studying this in the first place. She wasn't particularly interested in the benefits of greenery and nature. She was interested in the negative effects of noise and crowding. The way I got into the research on the effects of the natural environments on people was
这是否也适用于人类？鉴于人类最早进化于非洲的森林，剥夺人类这种自然环境会不会产生类似于把斑马关在笼子里的效果？我们一会儿就会探讨明对这个问题的答案，但首先重要的是要了解她最初是如何开始研究这个课题的。她并不是对绿化和自然的好处特别感兴趣。她感兴趣的是噪音和拥挤的负面影响。我之所以开始研究自然环境对人的影响，是因为
I was interested in the dark side of the environment. I was interested in how violent or dangerous or bad urban environments had detrimental effects on people. And I only got into this by accident. And then I only came up with this view of the effects of nature through the data. So I have been kind of dragged. I have been dragged into this all the way, kicking and screaming. I did not have that view of people
我对环境黑暗的一面感兴趣。我感兴趣的是城市环境如何具有暴力性、危险性或糟糕性，从而对人产生不利影响。我涉足这个领域纯属偶然。后来，我也只是通过数据才逐渐形成了这种关于自然影响的看法。所以我可以说是被硬拖进来的。我是一路踢打尖叫着被拉进来的。我对人们的看法并非
that I set out to test. I came upon that view because I was trying to make sense of what the findings have been. I'm glad you said that because you know this idea that people need greenery or that greenery is essential to human satisfaction, well-being, thriving. When I first heard that, I sort of said that sounds like a really feel-good idea that I could hear in a new age magazine. And I find it appealing that in some ways you were a skeptic yourself that for a long time, you found this idea to be sort of squishy.
源自我出发时想要检验的假设。我得出这种看法是因为我试图去理解研究结果的含义。我很高兴你这么说，因为你知道“人们需要绿化”或者“绿化对人类的满足感、幸福感、蓬勃发展至关重要”这种想法，当我第一次听到时，我有点觉得这听起来像是一个我在新时代杂志上能听到的那种让人感觉良好的观点。我觉得吸引人的是，在某种程度上，你自己曾经也是一个怀疑论者，在很长一段时间里，你觉得这个想法有点含糊不清。
Yeah. I think like a lot of people, I thought of the environment as trees, grass, gardens, flowers. I thought of that as kind of a nice amenity, they're not functional, right? They're not what we need. And so it's only when you look at the patterns of what people are like with more and less access to nature that you start to see this pattern where, gosh, you know, we
是的。我想和很多人一样，我把环境看作是树木、草地、花园、鲜花。我把这些看作是一种不错的便利设施，它们不是功能性的，对吧？它们不是我们所需要的。所以，只有当你观察人们在获得或多或少的自然接触时的模式时，你才会开始看到这样一种模式：天哪，你知道吗，我们
see the same thing in humans that we see in zoo and lab animals, which is the wonderful quote from E.O. Wilson is that organisms, when housed in unfit habitats, undergo social, psychological, and physical breakdown. And we are seeing precisely that in people. So when you have people who have a certain amount of access to nature, and then you give them a bit more, you see better social functioning, you see better psychological functioning and better physical health. In some ways this argument is saying that humans today or many humans today are living in the kind of conditions that we used to keep zoo
在人类身上看到了我们在动物园和实验室动物身上看到的东西，埃·奥·威尔逊（E.O. Wilson）有一句精彩的名言：生物如果被安置在不适合的栖息地中，就会经历社会、心理和生理上的崩溃。我们在人类身上也看到了确切的这种情况。因此，当人们拥有一定程度的自然接触，然后你再给他们多一点接触时，你会看到更好的社会功能、更好的心理功能和更好的身体健康。在某种程度上，这种观点是在说，今天的现代人类或许多现代人类正生活在50年前我们用来关动物园
animals in 50 years ago. I mean obviously we are doing better by a lot of humans than most zoo animals did in the old days but I think we are to some extent housing homo sapiens with that same functional view, that okay, well, as long as they have shelter, water, food, safety, you know, that's pretty good. That should do it, right? And then anything else beyond that is sort of a plus and it's nice. It's yummy, but it's not important. It's nice, it's yummy, but it's not important.
动物的那种条件中。我的意思是，很明显，我们对待许多人类的情况要比过去动物园里的大多数动物好得多，但我认为我们在某种程度上仍然以那种相同的功能性观点来安置智人，即：好吧，只要他们有住所、水、食物、安全，你知道的，这就相当不错了。这就够了，对吧？然后除此之外的任何东西都算是一种附加项，而且很美好。它令人愉悦，但并不重要。它令人愉快，令人垂涎，但并不重要。
I want to take you methodically through some of the empirical evidence that persuaded you that this was more than just a feel good theory. And I'm wondering if we could start with the studies that you and others have conducted in Chicago. Walk me through this research, starting with the study that you conducted
我想带你有条不紊地了解一些实证证据，这些证据说服了你，证明这不仅仅是一种感觉良好的理论。我想知道我们是否可以从你和其他人在芝加哥开展的研究开始。请带我了解一下这项研究，从你开展的研究开始
at the Robert Taylor Homes. Sure. So Robert Taylor Homes is a, or was, a series of 16, 10 story buildings, sort of along a particular corridor in Chicago. And they were originally designed with greenery all around them. But over time, as you can imagine, if you have a ton of kids running around in a courtyard space, you don't have much money for maintenance. If it rains, they get mud everywhere and the grass gets trampled and it very quickly tends to die. And so there are very few cases in which the building managers didn't end up just paving over what used to be grassy areas.
在罗伯特·泰勒住宅区（Robert Taylor Homes）。当然。所以罗伯特·泰勒住宅区是一个，或者说曾经是一个由16栋10层建筑组成的建筑群，沿着芝加哥的一条特定走廊分布。它们最初的设计是周围环绕着绿化。但随着时间的推移，你可以想象，如果你有一大群孩子在庭院空间里跑来跑去，你又没有太多钱用于维护。如果下雨，他们会弄得到处都是泥，草坪会被踩踏，并且很快就会枯死。因此，在极少数情况下，大楼管理者最终不得不把以前是草地的地方铺上路面。
And so if you pavor those areas, take the trees out, then you just have asphalt. So we have this beautiful kind of experiment where people are randomly assigned to different buildings that are identical and some of those buildings have a bit of trees and grass around them and some of them don't. And we just went about studying what the outcomes were in those different buildings. And what did you find? Well, we looked at a bunch of things but I think the sort of short answer is we found we found social breakdown in buildings without trees and grass around them.
因此，如果你把这些区域铺上路面，移走树木，那么你就只剩下柏油路了。所以我们有这样一个绝佳的实验，人们被随机分配到不同的完全相同的建筑中，其中一些建筑周围有一些树木和草地，而另一些则没有。然后我们着手研究这些不同建筑中的结果是什么。你发现了什么？嗯，我们研究了一系列的事情，但简短的回答是，我们发现在没有树木和草地环绕的建筑中，出现了社会崩溃。
That is to say, when we asked people, did they know their neighbors, did they speak to their neighbors, do they know them on first name basis, could they rely on their neighbors for, you know, for a favor to take care of their kids if they had an emergency. Then the people in the buildings with a bit of greenery were much more likely to say yes. We also found that the folks who are in the less green buildings are reporting more aggressive behaviors. And of course, we had reasons to think this might be the case according to theories.
也就是说，当我们问人们，他们是否认识邻居，是否与邻居交谈，是否知道邻居的名字，是否能在遇到紧急情况需要帮忙照顾孩子等事情时依赖邻居。那么居住在有一点绿化的建筑里的人更有可能回答“是”。我们还发现，身处绿化较少建筑中的人们表现出更多具有攻击性的行为。当然，根据理论，我们有理由认为情况会是这样。
So there's this attention restoration theory, which says that when people don't have access to nature they're going to be more mentally fatigued. So when you're mentally fatigued you're also less good at handling difficult social situations. And so we thought, okay, if nature is helpful for rejuvenating people from mental fatigue then folks in buildings who don't have any access to nature are going to be that much more fatigued and that much more irritable and that much more difficulty handling conflict in a productive way. And what's, of course, when we got these findings, we're kind of like, whoa, you know, I mean,
所以存在这样一种“注意力恢复理论”，它指出当人们无法接触自然时，他们会更容易产生精神疲劳。所以当你精神疲劳时，你应对困难社会情境的能力也会变差。所以我们想，好吧，如果大自然有助于让人从精神疲劳中恢复过来，那么没有任何自然接触的建筑中的人们将会更加疲劳，更加易怒，在以富有成效的方式处理冲突时也会遇到更多困难。当然，当我们得到这些发现时，我们有点像，哇，你知道我的意思，
I know the theory predicts this, but I didn't think we'd actually get it. And so I did a follow up when involving Chicago Police Department crime statistics. They were very good about giving us two years worth of crime statistics. From another development, we wanted to see if this general effect showed up in other Chicago public housing developments. So we looked at a low rise one instead of a high rise, and we see the same pattern in police records of crime. So it can't just be that people living in close proximity to trees maybe have rosier memories of their interactions with others. In fact, hypothetically, you're seeing maybe the same amount of disagreement and conflict, but people are just remembering it differently. You're saying
我知道理论预测了这一点，但我没想到我们真的能得到这样的结果。所以我进行了一项后续研究，涉及芝加哥警察局的犯罪统计数据。他们非常乐意提供给我们两年的犯罪统计数据。从另一个住宅区，我们想看看这种普遍效应是否也会在芝加哥的其他公共住宅区显现出来。因此，我们研究了一个低层住宅区而不是高层住宅区，我们在警察的犯罪记录中看到了同样的模式。所以，这不可能是因为住在树木附近的居民对彼此互动的记忆更加美好。事实上，假设来看，你看到的可能是不合和冲突的数量相同，但人们只是以不同的方式记住了它们。你的意思是
the police records in some ways provide an objective measure that there actually is less conflict in these buildings. Right, exactly. So, I'm wondering about other confounding things in the study. I mean, is it possible that apartment buildings with more green space had different numbers of people living in them? You know, the buildings themselves were identical, but is it possible there were fewer people for some reason living in the greener buildings? And what you're measuring is really related to crowding and not related to green space.
警察记录在某种程度上提供了一个客观的衡量标准，证明这些建筑中的冲突实际上确实减少了。是的，完全正确。所以，我在想研究中其他混杂的因素。我的意思是，绿化空间较多的公寓楼里居住的人数会不会不同？你知道，建筑物本身是完全相同的，但由于某种原因，绿化较多的建筑里居住的人会不会更少？而你所测量的其实与拥挤有关，而与绿化空间无关。
Good question. But as you remember, those were the variables I cared about. So I wanted about, is there more noise, or was there more crowding? What else is going on in these buildings? And so, because I was interested, I made sure to measure all of those things. And it turns out that those did not explain their relationship.
好问题。但正如你所记得的，那些正是我关心的变量。所以我关心的是，噪音是否更大，或者拥挤程度是否更高？这些建筑里还发生了什么？因此，因为我对此感兴趣，我确保测量了所有这些事情。事实证明，这些并没有解释它们之间的关系。
So let's just take crowding as an example. If there was crowding, then it didn't fit the pattern that the violence fit, or it didn't fit the pattern of the green space, or both. I understand there's been research done out of Columbia University in the University of Pennsylvania that has explored what happens when you green parts of a city add more trees and grass to parts of a city that this has measurable effects not just from the quality of life but even on the crime rate. Right, and the numbers are really pretty startling. So these researchers worked with the city to coordinate their vacant lot program. And basically what they did was they designated a bunch of vacant lots as eligible for cleaning
所以我们以拥挤为例。如果有拥挤，那么它就不符合暴力事件呈现的模式，或者它不符合绿化空间呈现的模式，或者两者都不符合。据我所知，哥伦比亚大学和宾夕法尼亚大学开展了一项研究，探讨当你在城市的某些地方增加绿化、在城市的某些地方增加更多的树木和草地时会发生什么，这不仅对生活质量产生了可衡量的影响，甚至对犯罪率也有影响。是的，这个数字确实相当惊人。因此，这些研究人员与市政府合作，协调他们的空置地块计划。基本上，他们做的是指定了一批空置地块，使其有资格进行清理
and greening. Quote unquote. So that involves taking out all the trash, bits of glass, cigarette butts, cleaning it up, putting in some turf grass, you know, nice panel of lawn, and then some trees. So fairly inexpensive intervention, and they randomly assigned which lots would get this intervention and which ones would not, and then they tracked what happened in those lots afterwards.
和绿化。所谓的绿化。这包括清理所有垃圾、玻璃碎片、烟头，将其清理干净，铺上一些草皮，你知道的，一块漂亮的草坪，然后种上一些树木。因此，这是一项相当便宜的干预措施，他们随机分配哪些地块将接受这种干预，哪些地块不会，然后他们追踪了这些地块之后发生的情况。
And it turns out that in the lots that receive this intervention, gun assaults go down by police records, 9.1%, which is really, like, boy, if we have anything that cost any amount of money that can reduce gun assaults by 9% in a city, any mayor in the US is going to trump at that. And we see similar patterns for burglaries and other complaints. So, it's a very exciting finding.
事实证明，在接受了这项干预的地块中，根据警方记录，枪击事件减少了9.1%，这真的让人觉得，天啊，如果我们有任何花了一定资金、能够使一个城市的枪击事件减少9%的措施，美国任何一位市长都会为此欢呼雀跃。我们在入室盗窃和其他投诉中也看到了类似的模式。所以，这是一个非常令人兴奋的发现。
If I recall correctly, wasn't there a time maying when actually police had the opposite intuition? They actually thought that having trees and bushes could actually increase crime because it gave bad guys places to hide and in some ways it made surveillance easier if you actually eliminated all of that and that's just that open lots or just things paved over. Right, there was that belief and in fact there is something to that intuition but it's fairly limited. So if you have a lot of basically brush and undercover,
如果我没记错的话，明，是不是曾有一段时间，警察的直觉其实恰好相反？他们实际上认为，有树木和灌木实际上可能会增加犯罪，因为这给坏人提供了藏身之处，而在某种程度上，如果你把所有这些都清除掉，只剩下开阔的地块或铺砌过的地面，反而会让监控变得更容易。是的，曾经有过这种信念，事实上，这种直觉也有一定的道理，但它是相当有限的。因此，如果你有很多灌木丛和底层植被，
that can in certain circumstances, particularly in park settings, depending on lines of visibility, then yes, a large bush can provide a place to hide drugs or a gun or whatever. And at the same time, what we see is that if you have limbed up trees, trees that do not block visibility at eye level, the consistent finding is more trees less crime. What was your reaction being as a researcher in some ways who wasn't necessarily looking for this finding?
在某些情况下，特别是在公园环境中，根据视线情况，是的，一个大灌木丛可以提供一个藏匿毒品、枪支或其他东西的地方。与此同时，我们看到的是，如果你有修剪过下部枝杈的树木、也就是那些不阻挡视线在眼睛高度的树木，得到的一致发现是：树木越多，犯罪越少。作为一名研究人员，你在某种程度上并不是非要寻找这个发现，你的反应是什么？
And in some ways, as I'm detecting, was sort of somewhat skeptical about sort of the overall relationship between nature and these positive things. What was your reaction when you got these results? I mean, to be a scientist, to be a good scientist is to be a skeptic, you know. So even when you have a theory that's your pet theory and this was by no means my pet theory. Your job is to try to figure out is there some way this we could have found this without my pet theory being true. And so I'll tell you a related story. My old advisor, Rachel Kaplan, who's one of the giants in this field, she did her work for decades
而且在某种程度上，正如我所察觉到的，你对自然与这些积极事物之间的整体关系持某种程度的怀疑态度。当你得到这些结果时，你的反应是什么？我的意思是，要成为一名科学家，一名优秀的科学家，就必须是一个怀疑论者。所以，即使你有一个你最钟爱的理论，而这绝不是我最钟爱的理论。你的工作是试图弄清楚，有没有什么方法让我们能够发现这一点，而我的宠儿理论并不是真的。所以我给你讲一个相关的故事。我的老导师蕾切尔·卡普兰（Rachel Kaplan），她是这个领域的泰斗之一，她进行了几十年的研究
in a building at the University of Michigan that faces onto a brick interior courtyard, just bricks and gravel at the bottom. So she spends her career there 30, 40 years. I don't know how many years, right? And then over time, she does stpendous work and the university finally decides to give her a named chair, a professorship, sort of a very fancy position. And at the same time, they're renovating the building and they move Rachel into a third
在密歇根大学的一栋大楼里，这栋楼面向一个砖砌的内部庭院，底部只有砖块和砾石。所以她在那里度过了她的职业生涯，30年，40年。我不知道是多少年，对吧？随着时间的推移，她做出了惊人的工作，大学最终决定为她设立一个冠名讲座教授职位，即一种非常高级的职位。与此同时，他们正在翻修大楼，并将蕾切尔搬到了三楼。
floor corner office in the trees. It's right in the canopy. And her office is all windows. And she says to me, you know, I have been studying this for how many decades, and now I know it's really true. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. For years, Minkuo has studied how nature affects us and how the lack of access to nature can lead to crime and social breakdown. It turns out this is only part of the story. There's also a relationship between nature and our physical and mental health.
楼角的办公室，里面全是树木。它就在树冠中。她的办公室全是窗户。她对我说，你知道，我研究这个已经不知多少十年了，现在我知道这是真的。这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。多年来，明国一直在研究大自然如何影响我们，以及缺乏接触自然如何导致犯罪和社会崩溃。事实证明，这只是故事的一部分。大自然与我们的身心健康之间也存在联系。
Ming says there seems to be a connection between greenery and health markers for obesity, hypertension, and diabetes. So I did a review of the scientific literature and I found every bit of evidence I could that tied greenery to long-term health outcomes. So for instance, one of the things we find is that when you look out at a green landscape even from indoors, your heart rate will go down and you'll change from sympathetic
明说，绿化与肥胖、高血压和糖尿病的健康指标之间似乎存在某种联系。因此，我查阅了科学文献，找到了我能找到的所有将绿化与长期健康结果联系起来的证据。例如，我们发现的一件事是，当你望向绿色的景观时，即使在室内，你的心率也会下降，你将从交感神经活动
nervous activity over to parasympathetic nervous activity, which is basically going from what we call fight or flight into tend and befriend mode. So it has these very systematic physiological impacts on us, which we also know have long-term health outcomes associated with them. And I found dozens of health outcomes where long-term health outcomes had been tied to contact with nature, and all of those studies, I threw out anything that didn't take into account
神经活动转变为副交感神经活动，这基本上是从我们所说的“战斗或逃跑”模式转变为“抚育与结盟”模式。因此，它对我们产生了非常系统的生理影响，我们也知道这些影响与长期的健康结果相关。我发现了数十种健康结果，长期的健康结果与接触自然有关，在所有这些研究中，我剔除了任何没有考虑
socioeconomic status. It is no surprise that we would find rich people tend to have greener neighborhoods and better health outcomes. I was interested in let's take two people, same income, same life circumstances, except for the greenery. And what do we see in terms of health outcomes there? Let's talk a little bit about the socio-economic surface. As you and others have pointed out, there is an enormous disparity in many countries, not just between the rich and the poor, but in neighborhoods that are green and neighborhoods that are not green. And in many ways, this lines up with disparities between the rich and the poor.
社会经济地位的因素。我们发现富人往往拥有更绿化的社区和更好的健康结果，这并不令人意外。我感兴趣的是，让我们假设两个人，收入相同，生活环境相同，唯一的区别是绿化。那么我们在那里的健康结果中会看到什么？让我们稍微谈谈社会经济层面。正如你和其他人所指出的，在许多国家存在着巨大的差距，不仅在富人和穷人之间，而且在有绿化的社区和没有绿化的社区之间。在许多方面，这与富人和穷人之间的差距相吻合。
Rich neighborhoods tend to be greener, poor neighborhoods tend to be less green. How much of what you are seeing is it possible that some of this is actually just related to differences in wealth that then produce all kinds of other health consequences, or do you think this is actually connected just to the greenery itself? Well, that's exactly the concern, right? We already knew that wealthier people have better health outcomes and more greenery, so then how do you compare? And basically, what you do is you look for people who have the exact same person A in the screen neighborhood and person B in the snacking neighborhood, you want to make sure persons A and B have the same income. So all of these comparisons in
富裕的社区往往更绿化，贫穷的社区往往绿化较少。在你所看到的情况中，有多少可能是这实际上只与财富的差异有关，而财富又产生了各种其他健康后果，或者你认为这实际上仅与绿化本身有关？嗯，这正是令人关切的问题，对吧？我们已经知道，较富裕的人拥有更好的健康结果和更多的绿化，那么你如何进行比较呢？基本上，你所做的是寻找那些完全相同的人——在绿色社区的A先生和在非绿色社区的B先生，你想要确保A先生和B先生有相同的收入。所以在所有这些比较中
this review I did were taking that into account. One of my favorite studies in this area comes from an analysis of pharmacies in London and the medications they dispense. And there's a connection between this and the amount of greenery in different neighborhoods in London. What are the study fine? So pharmacies in London are neighborhood-based. So pretty much people go to the pharmacy that's in their neighborhood.
我做的这篇综述考虑了这一点。我最喜欢的研究之一来自对伦敦药房及其配发的药物的分析。这与伦敦不同社区的绿化程度之间存在联系。研究发现了什么？所以伦敦的药房是基于社区的。因此，几乎人们都会去他们社区里的药房。
And they know how green it is around each pharmacy. And they also know how many people live there, how many people the pharmacy serves. And they know prescriptions for mood related, you know, anxiety disorder medications and depression medications. And they just compared for pharmacies that compare the same number of people with the same rough income. How many more mood medications are they prescribing? And it's substantially larger.
他们知道每个药房周围有多绿。他们还知道那里住了多少人，药房服务了多少人。他们知道与情绪相关的处方药，你知道的，焦虑症药物和抑郁症药物。他们只是对服务相同人数、收入大致相同的药房进行了比较。他们开出的情绪药物多了多少？而且这个差距相当大。
The less greenery is around the neighborhood. There also appears to be a relationship between greenery and the strength of our immune systems. After people spend several days in nature, researchers find measurable increases in what are known as natural killer cells. After a three-day weekend in a forest preserve, that boosts natural killer cells on average by 50%. And a three-day weekend in a nice urban area turns out doesn't do anything for your natural killer cells. And then if I come, come knock on your door 30 days later after your three-day weekend, and I say, can I have another sample of your blood please?
社区周边的绿化越少，开药量就越多。绿化与我们免疫系统的强度之间似乎也存在着联系。在人们在大自然中度过几天之后，研究人员发现被称为自然杀手细胞的数量有了可测量的增加。在森林自然保护区度过一个三天的周末后，平均能使自然杀手细胞增加50%。而在一个不错的城市地区度过一个三天的周末，结果证明对你的自然杀手细胞没有任何作用。然后，如果我来，在你的三天周末之后的第30天敲你的门，我说，请问我能再要一份你的血样吗？
And you give it to me. It will show that you are still roughly 24, 25 percent above your baseline number of natural killer cells. So it's a big effect and it lasts for a really long time. What do you think is going on here, Ming? I mean, is it just the things we see when we're out in nature, is the things we smell, is it just the things we see when we're out in nature, is it things we smell, is it just the experience of being out in nature, is it the perception, is that what's driving these effects, do you think? Well, the answer is yes.
然后你把它交给我。它将显示你的自然杀手细胞数量仍然比基线水平高出大约24%、25%。所以这是一个巨大的影响，而且持续时间真的很长。明，你认为这里面发生了什么？我的意思是，这仅仅是我们去大自然中看到的东西，还是我们闻到的东西，仅仅是我们去大自然中看到的、闻到的东西，仅仅是置身于大自然中的体验，是这种感知在驱动这些效果吗？嗯，答案是“是的”。
So it turns out that if we take people and put them in a lab, and we just show them pictures of nature, and we watch what happens to their blood pressure and their nervous system activity. We can see them become more calm. So just the visual is enough. Similarly, if I take you into a lab and I spritz what we call fight insides, which are these essential aromatic compounds that you associate with woods. So if I spritz you with fight insides,
事实证明，如果我们把人们带进实验室，只给他们看自然的照片，并观察他们的血压和神经系统活动会发生什么。我们可以看到他们变得更加平静。所以仅凭视觉就足够了。同样地，如果我把你带进实验室，喷洒我们所谓的“植物杀菌素”（phytoncides），这些是你与森林联系在一起的精油芳香化合物。所以如果我给你喷洒植物杀菌素，
you don't have to be in a pine forest. I can see changes in your natural killer cells and in your bloodstream. So of course, if you're a mad scientist, you would say, well, really all you have to do is make sure that people's green savers are set to pictures of forests. And you sort of pipe in some, you know,
你不需要身处松林中。我就可以看到你体内自然杀手细胞和血流发生变化。所以当然，如果你是一个疯狂的科学家，你会说，好吧，你真正需要做的就是确保人们的绿色屏障被设置为森林的照片。然后你通过公共广播系统播放一些，你知道的，
sounds of the forest over the public address system, and you spritz the air with some eucalyptus, and you're done. Well, you will have a measurable positive effect. If I give you vitamin D, and I give you vitamin A, then that takes care of your D and A deficiency, but it doesn't take care of your B and C deficiencies. So nature seems to be like a multivitamin. You can get different benefits from different kinds of exposure, you know, right, the spritzing versus the visual versus the smell or whatever. But to get all of them, you have kind of have to be there.
森林的声音，并在空气中喷洒一些桉树精油，你就大功告成了。嗯，你将会产生可测量的积极效果。如果我给你维生素D，再给你维生素A，那么这解决了你的D和A缺乏症，但它并没有解决你的B和C缺乏症。所以大自然似乎就像一种复合维生素。你可以从不同类型的接触中获得不同的好处，你知道的，对吧，喷洒与视觉与气味等等。但要获得所有的好处，你基本上必须亲自去那里。
So I'm wondering how do you take this multivitamin everyday, Ming? You've started out as a skeptic and you've gradually come to be persuaded by the evidence. Have you found ways to actually apply these insights to your own life? I live about a 10 minute walk from the university from the campus and I do something which probably looks completely ridiculous to the average person driving by me. I walk two and from school with my eyes in the canopy. I fly through the trees on the way to school and I fly through the trees on the way back from campus. And I have, so my head is up, I probably at danger of tripping, I look ridiculous, but
所以我想知道，明，你每天是如何服用这种复合维生素的？你一开始是一个怀疑论者，然后逐渐被证据说服。你是否找到了将这些见解应用到自己生活中的方法？我住在距离大学校园大约步行10分钟的地方，我做了一件在开车路过我的普通人看来可能极其荒谬的事情。我上学和放学路上都把眼睛盯着树冠。我在去学校的路上穿梭于树木之间，在从校园回来的路上也穿梭于树木之间。而且我，我的头抬着，我可能面临绊倒的危险，我看起来很可笑，但
it makes a real difference for me. And once I started adopting that, I have become hooked. Ming-Ko's studies the effects that nature has on human beings. come hooked. Ming Co. studies the effects that nature has on human beings. She's a researcher at the University of Illinois at Urbana-Champaign. Ming, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. This week's show was produced by Thomas Liu and edited by Tara Boyle.
这对我产生了真正的改变。一旦我开始采取这种做法，我就迷上了。明国研究大自然对人类的影响。我迷上了。明·国研究大自然对人类的影响。她是伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-香槟分校的研究员。明，非常感谢你今天来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢。本周的节目由托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。
Artimian Clude Zrena Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah and Laura Correll. Our unsung hero is Emily Blackman, who oversees events at the Chesapeake Bay Foundation. We had a staff retreat at the Foundation's headquarters some time ago, and Emily made sure that everything ran smoothly. Her work gave us a chance to take a breath and connect with nature and with each other. It was a wonderful day and we're truly grateful. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please be sure to share it with someone you know. We're always looking for new listeners
Artimian Clude Zrena Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah and Laura Correll. 我们的无名英雄是艾米丽·布莱克曼（Emily Blackman），她负责监督切萨皮克湾基金会（Chesapeake Bay Foundation）的活动。前一段时间我们在基金会总部举办了员工休假，艾米丽确保了一切顺利进行。她的工作让我们有机会喘口气，与大自然以及彼此建立联系。那是非常美好的一天，我们由衷地感激。想了解更多Hidden Brain，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这期节目，请务必把它分享给你认识的人。我们一直在寻找新听众
to Hidden Brain. We're always looking for new listeners to hit and brain. Next week, authenticity is contagious. We continue our YouTube.O series with an episode about rebelling against norms. Once we see people making themselves vulnerable rather than judging them negatively, we actually respect them and we ask ourselves questions about why is it that we're covering up. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加入Hidden Brain。我们一直在寻找新听众加入Hidden Brain。下周，真实具有传染性。我们继续我们的YouTube.O系列节目，探讨反叛规范的一集。一旦我们看到人们表现出脆弱而不是对他们进行负面评价，我们实际上会尊重他们，我们会问自己为什么我们要进行掩饰。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦，这里是NPR。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子来留下评论。